energy
[Music]
culture in Singapore how are you I'm
good how are you I'm good oh my God I
love your bangs oh thank you now Titania
is your over the top self-obsessed
influencer
um tell me about the time you met an
influencer who embodied all these traits
I have never met an influencer who
embodies all these traits because I
deliberately stay away from the kind of
spaces in which I would come across
those sorts of people but
I live online you know so we all know
who these people are and I got to pull
little bits from each of them and create
Titania as a kind of collage of just all
the worst people on the internet
no I love that because I could I could
see it uh but totally I'm a medicine two
ends one why it's not where you think uh
influenza climate who would have more
engagement you or her oh God I think
that my character would try harder but I
think Madison is just someone who is so
naturally enigmatic that I think Madison
would actually win but Titania would do
everything possible to sabotage her if
Christians yeah so what is your heart
take on influenza culture though
oh I think influences can be fine I just
think that the ones who sell products
that don't really help people and who
sell a fake unattainable lifestyle and
appearance oh kind of the villains of
Our Generation and so it felt very
fitting and very clever of just a girl
to write a super villain as that because
they have the power of these huge
platforms and so they they really
they really do a lot of damage and it
was really fun and important I think to
satirize them that felt better than
scolding them finding a way to kind of
show how ridiculous it is that that
people behave in the way that Titania
does is is I think quite effective to
have that conversation in a way that
feels a bit more tongue-in-cheek what
will it take for a Titania to have it on
series
oh I don't know but that would be so fun
and so ridiculous and so full of
celebrities I imagine yeah
uh yeah that would be wild but I I would
love that it would take the fan base
liking me and and pushing for something
like that I imagine but I have no idea
I'm not going to count my chickens if I
get to do anything else in Marvel I will
be really happy even if it's catering
actually thinking about anything else in
Marvel where else in the MCU do you
think Titania will pop up or where do
you want to pop up well the character's
got beef with everyone she's got beef
with Spider-Man with Thor like I can
like with I mean all of the X-Men I mean
there could be place for her in
Thunderbolts or there could be a place
for her in Deadpool like there's so many
she's she really is hated by everyone
and so it's a wealth of possibility for
me I I've chosen the most annoying
character in the MCU just chef's kiss
yeah and so hopefully I get to do it
again I would love to and and I uh
something happens to me when I put on
that red wig it brings on this new
confident Persona that I could never
muster on my own so I'm really really
really enjoys playing her and I'm really
grateful to cat coiro for pushing me to
try out for this role I'm glad that you
try it out anyways because you're
perfect
I'm just curious to know though so you
said that she's really confident and
everything but where does her dislike
for She-Hulk come from like is it
jealousy or like I don't know well she's
not really confident I don't think
anyone is truly confident behaves like
that I think she's really insecure but
her problem with She-Hulk is just that
Titania is a misogynist right she buys
into misogynist values she looks in a
way that patriarchy tells women to look
and files down her nose and overlines
her lips and she's got the big fake
boobs and then the tiny corseted waist
and big fake but you know and I think on
top of that she believes that there
could only ever be one girl at a time
one strong powerful tall woman at a time
and so I think she follows that scarcity
mindset to just want to destroy any
woman who comes along and tries to take
her place woman or man Titania
throughout the years has got beef truly
with everyone and anyone she feels
threatened by and so that's all it is is
just the wrong place wrong time for
Jennifer Walters
[Music]
[Music]